Speaker 1: I'm going to play a clip for you here
of a Trump supporter talking about homelessness.
Now, homelessness is a very important issue.
Homelessness is a moral failing of the United
States. There's no reason we have to have
homelessness in the United States. There's
also no reason we have to have hunger, but we
lack a political will and sort of resolution
to decide we're not going to do it anymore. But
this is interesting. Here is a Trump supporter
complaining about homelessness. She says
something very interesting. She says she
doesn't see Hispanics out on the street. She
sees blacks and whites. What does she mean
by this? What's the truth of it? And what
the hell is going on here? Let's listen.
Speaker 2: There's been some of the negative
things since Biden. You know, you turn your
head and you pause for dramatic effect.
Speaker 3: But to be honest with.
Speaker 2: You, I mean, what we're.
Speaker 3: Seeing so many homeless in
my life ever. Never in my life have I ever seen
so many homeless. And it's like, okay, we're
going to take we're going to have open borders. I
never see any of the Hispanics on the street. What
I see is African American and Caucasian American.
Speaker 1: What is she trying to make in terms of
a point here? I don't is the point she's trying
to make that Hispanics are hard workers and they
don't end up homeless or something like is she
is this praise of Hispanic Americans, Hispanic
women? At what point is she trying to make now?
The math is sort of interesting. In reality,
it's estimated that about 24% of those who were
homeless in 2022 were Hispanic. And that's that's
an overrepresentation relative to the 19% of the
population that Hispanics are believed to make
up. So 19% of the population, 24% of homeless
Hispanics are overrepresented in the homeless
population. But I don't know what that proves
one way or the other. Just as usual, these folks
are wrong on the facts and their analysis and
commentary is is weird. Now, I do want to mention
how do people end up homeless? Because there is
this idea among many on the right that when you're
homeless, it's the result of a personal failure. I
actually was at a restaurant the other day. There
was a guy there with his daughter and also his
his girlfriend. It clearly wasn't the daughter's
mom. It was but it was his girlfriend and with
his daughter. And I overheard this guy saying,
if you're hungry in this country, it's by choice.
And then 5 minutes later, he yelled at his
daughter. And then later at his girlfriend, very
loudly in front of a restaurant full of people.
It was super cringe. So that's that guy's the one
who was saying, if you're hungry in this country,
it's by choice. The truth is that homelessness
in the United States is often the result of
structural factors poverty, lack of affordable
housing, major issue, not enough housing,
unemployment, low wages, discrimination, domestic
violence, mental illness, substance abuse, abuse,
lack of social support. All of those things can
affect anybody, regardless of race, ethnicity,
gender, age or background. But it is true that
there are historically marginalized communities
that are more likely to be affected by some of
those issues. One other thing. There's this myth
that homeless people are lazy or dangerous. This
is also not true as far as lazy. The vast majority
of the poor and many of the homeless actually do
work. That's number one. And then number two, this
idea of criminality, home, homeless criminality.
The vast majority of homeless people have never
committed any criminal act other than if a city
makes it a crime to be home. Less than you are
criminalizing their very status. And we've talked
about that happening in a number of different
cities. So not sure what point this woman was
trying to make, but at least it gives us an
opportunity to talk about homelessness. Let's take
a quick break. We'll be right back. I will very
briefly remind you that the David Pakman show is
an audience supported program. We primarily depend
on people who get a membership at join Packman
dot com. We package up a whole bunch of great
goodies for those that do including the world
famous and award winning bonus show. Yeah its
awards we've completely made up and we were the
only people in the in the running for but still
they are awards you can sign up at join Packman
dot com and use the coupon code 24 starts now you
can also get the children's critical thinking book
now over 5000 copies sold at David Packman dot com
slash book remember to leave a review if you've
purchased the book over the last week or so.